backwards compatibility was an iffy  thing when we jumped from the xbox 360  to the Xbox one but what about project  Scorpio I'm Tony and this is your  reassuring gamespot news update the  backwards compatibility program  currently supports more than 250 xbox  360 games on the Xbox one from RPGs like  lost odyssey and blue dragon to shooters  like Rainbow Six Vegas and halo reach  and xbox executive Mike ibarra confirmed  on Twitter that all of these games will  indeed work on the Scorpio so if you  plan on upgrading you won't lose any of  your compatible games project Scorpios  real name and price haven't been  revealed yet but it goes on sale and  holiday 2017 meanwhile Sony's  four-hundred-dollar playstation 4 pro  hit store shelves on november 10th to  keep up with all the latest video game  consoles you're already in the right  place